[Music]
you see
doctor god didn't make that movie
fate didn't butcher it and destiny
didn't feed it to the fanboys if
god saw what was done that night he
didn't seem to mind
from then on i knew god didn't make the
watchman movie this way
zack snyder did
[Music]
comic book writer alan moore first
conceived of what would eventually
become
watchmen shortly after dc comics
acquired the rights to a collection of
heroes previously published
under the defunct charlton comics he
wanted to revamp and reimagine the
characters
before taking them into a dark new
direction
he'd actually done this a few years
earlier with miracle man
a character originally published under
fawcett comics
he pitched his concept to dc chief dick
giordano
who liked the story but realized quickly
that what moore was planning to do
would render the newly acquired
characters virtually unusable
in future projects and dc hadn't bought
the rights to these things just to burn
the characters off in one story
so he convinced moore to create new
characters
most of whom were thinly veiled
pastiches that devoted comic fans would
see through anyway
dave gibbons was brought in for the
artwork having worked with moore before
on among other things the legendary
superman story for the man who has
everything
the first issue of watchmen landed in
september
1986 and was concluded in 12 issues
shaking the comic book world to its core
in the process with its dark dystopian
world on the brink of destruction
it's amoral and broken characters who
had little
to no right to be called heroes and its
complete
deconstruction of the entire superhero
genre
ushering in what is now thought of as
the dark age
of comics now truth is that's actually a
bit of an oversimplification the uh
the so-called bronze age of comics had
already been taking things in a more
dark and consequences driven direction
since
the start of the 70s the groundwork had
been laid at dc with stories like
that one where green arrow's sidekick
becomes a drug addict meanwhile over a
marvel there were stories like the death
of gwen stacy
and chris claremont's work with the
x-men but things like the dark phoenix
saga
and god loves man kills but 1985 stills
feels like a good year to
draw the line at for the end of the
bronze age because in 1986
you had not only watchmen but you also
had
frank miller's the dark knight returns
earlier that same year
now people will usually point to
watchmen
first because well because it wasn't
written by an out and proud xenopho who
seems to have since lost his
understanding of heroes altogether
so let that be your main lesson today
kids
it's less embarrassing to be an
anarchist
than a racist
[Music]
we're not really here to talk about that
we're here to talk about that time in
2009 when zack snyder made it into a
movie
a movie that has caused some of the
most heated movie-based arguments i've
ever gotten into
first upon its initial release they were
arguments with people who said that it
totally works
actually and then in years since the
argument has been with people who
disagree with me about why it doesn't
work because
i've seen a ton of think pieces and
breakdowns that pick over every single
tiny detail that was changed
altered or omitted whether it be john
going to retrieve
his own watch instead of getting one
that he fixed for janie or
inserting janie into the tv interview
confrontation or dan not having a gut
as if a catalog of such things might
reveal the exact missing piece
that brought it all down there are some
more sophisticated analyses out there
that might point to potential
misunderstanding of certain elements by
snyder
and his team with rorschach coming off
as cool when he should be repulsive
and action scenes that are thrilling
when they should be off-putting and
uncomfortable but while i don't think
any of those things are
not issues and they certainly don't help
none of this is the true
heart of the problem with this movie
because even if these changes editions
omissions
were reversed the film still wouldn't
work
because it's not what snyder changed
that doom the film is what he didn't
the 2009 film version of watchmen is too
loyal to the source material
in a way that i for one have always
found fascinating
so let's talk about it
just a quick note because i know it's
going to get brought up if i don't
address it i've now seen
three different cuts of this movie
theatrical directors and
ultimate i really shouldn't have had to
do that because when my argument is
it's too loyal to the original that's
not an argument that's going to be
diminished
by putting in even more stuff
from the comic but i did it anyway
so that nobody can tell me that if i'd
watched a different cut of the movie
i'd be saying something else
and also for the record as i anticipated
each successive cut made the issues i'm
focusing on worse
and i'm even going to pull some examples
from them so there you go
with that out of the way let me kind of
jump to the end
and explain that the core of what i'm
going to be talking about
is really the differences in artistic
mediums
every form of media has certain things
that it doesn't do very well or indeed
things that it doesn't do at all a novel
doesn't have images
a comic book doesn't have sound a film
doesn't have interactivity and a video
game
while you can do many things with it it
doesn't allow for a passive experience
additionally some mediums have tricks
unique to them or at least
absent from most other forms of media
there are aspects of live theater that
can't be recreated without the
interactions
between performer and audience
the freedom of a novel reader to
envision the world and the characters as
they
see without having the visuals dictated
to them
doesn't exist in film or television or
comics
the interactive nature of video games
offers whole new
worlds of experiences when it comes to
adapting any given piece of work
from one medium to another there are any
number of things
that are going to make that difficult
but to my way of thinking
the big one is as follows
how precisely was the work tailored to
its original medium
because the more a piece of work takes
advantage of the unique
traits of the medium it was originally
told in the harder it's going to be
to adapt it to a medium that doesn't
have those same traits
my shorthand example of this is the film
adaptation
of the stage musical into the woods
you may not have seen it doesn't matter
because i'm going to explain anyway
reviews on that film were mixed for a
variety of reasons but
among the most consistent criticisms was
a jarring tone shift that hits
a little more than halfway into the film
that shift is in the play
too but it works there because it's
built around something
currently unique to live theater the
intermission
so just in case you're not familiar with
the show or the movie it plays around
with a bunch of fairy tale characters
and plots and the end of the first
act everything seems to have been tied
up
in a rather neat little bow there's a
big happily ever after song
the lights come up you stretch you use
the bathroom and
probably about halfway through the
intermission
the thought hits you hey
that really did feel like an ending what
the heck is going to happen in the
second act
that time during which the story stops
gives your brain a chance to catch up
reset and then prepare for the other
shoe to drop
you may not know exactly what's coming
but you had the intermission to realize
that
something was coming so when
it does you're better prepared to roll
with it
but a film has no intermission it just
steamrolls
right through the tone shift and it
results in complete emotional whiplash
for any viewer who didn't know in
advance that that was going to happen
the stage version took advantage of
something unique to theater and the film
failed to account for that and just
adapted it straight
to a new medium that doesn't work the
same
way this is actually also the same
reason
why a lot of lovecraft adaptations don't
work
in a novel you can actually get away
with vague imagery and calling the rest
indescribable in a film you
have to show it and that undermines the
whole idea of incomprehensibility and
that idea is at the heart of most of
lovecraft's work
well that in the racism but i will move
on from that
but this is the kind of thing that we're
going to be looking at
as i talk about the watchmen film
because
alan moore is a very particular kind of
writer
most comic book writers assuming they
aren't also the artist
when they script for a company like dc
they will detail the events the
characters obviously the dialogue and
what they consider to be the most
important specifics after that usually a
great deal will be left up to the artist
when it comes to things like
background details specifics of the
character poses
sometimes even the panel layout alan
moore
does not write like that he details
everything that he wants to see on a
panel right
down to the slogan on a coffee mug
he's an extremely exacting writer and
nothing appears in the watchman comics
that wasn't
put there with purpose by him
that's not to downplay the contributions
of artist dave givens
only to say that he was working within
very exacting specifications given to
him by more
alan moore is exactly the kind of writer
who is going to create something
tailored to the
last detail for the medium of comic
books
now it's easy enough for me to say that
maybe i should give you some specific
examples
the big one is actually the panel layout
watchman's pages are laid out in a nine
panel
three by three grid on occasion where an
image needs to make more impact it might
take up
two or even three of say the bottom
panels or
maybe one or even two out of three of
the vertical columns but
the layout is still always identifiable
as the same three by three setup
this creates a rhythm for the reader a
consistent
pace it's like the ticking of a
metronome interrupted by select doses
of holding a beat for a few panels
longer than usual
to draw attention snyder appears to have
decided that the film equivalent
to taking up a couple more panels is to
go into slow motion which
on paper is logical but the effect is
actually
quite different the thing about giving
more panel space to an image
is that it does absolutely draw more
attention to that but it also doesn't
demand that you
spend any longer looking at it than you
would at a standard panel
it emphasizes without actually slowing
down
but slow motion well slowing down is all
that it does
so while it may bring emphasis to these
same moments
it does so in a way that kills the
rhythm
which doesn't happen on the comic book
page
what the comic is able to do is bring
special attention to a scene
or character organically with
minimal breaking of flow that is until
the book deliberately
decides to break that flow
in the last chapter the final issue of
this comic opens with
six successive splash pages that's
comic book lingo for a full page image
depicting
death and destruction in new york the
comfort of the grid
is gone there is literally nothing for
you to look at beside the horror
of the scene and the first two page
turns
will bring you no respite there is no
possible way to miss the impact of this
because of how it
shatters the orderly and economic
presentation of the comic up to that
point
and film doesn't really have a technique
to match that
yes you can slow the scene down yes you
can pipe in dramatic music yes you can
have a longer continuous shot
but for it to truly have the same impact
as these pages in terms of breaking its
own format the film would have had to
have had no slow motion and no musical
score
up until that point otherwise it's
just not the same it's not as jarring
it can't be the medium doesn't allow for
it and it was written to take very
specific advantage of the comic book
format and the entire story is tailored
to maximize
that moment
[Music]
okay so more writes for his medium so
what so does any creator worth their
salt
but it's more than just some of the
specifics that i've started laying out
it's also about the pace at which the
story is even meant to be read
i don't mean panel to panel or page to
page pacing i touched on that already
this time i mean the pacing from issue
to issue
watchmen is a deliberately dense
piece of work every element in every
panel on
every page is there deliberately and it
has purpose
and meaning and to be blunt it's meant
to be taken in slowly
one issue at a time for anyone who
hasn't read the comic and just picks up
the trade paperback
i always advise that they not burn
through that thing as fast as they can
you need to take no more than one issue
a night
i actually tend to advise people taking
more time than that between issues
because moore didn't make it this dense
to be pretentious he did it because
there was going to be a full
month between each issue and he
wanted the reader to be revisiting and
thinking
about the previous issue and the ones
that came before
in that time pouring over the details
better understanding the world
the gap is part of the intended
experience that's part of the purpose of
things like the tales of the black
freighter
it glides along as an odd detail on
first reading a little strange but
when it's first introduced it's not flow
breaking because it crops up as one
maybe two panels on the grid of nine
but going back and lingering on the odd
details
while you're waiting for the next issue
is where you'll start to understand why
it's there
and that will help you understand its
relevance ahead
of when it starts taking up entire pages
readers are meant to absorb it and
grapple with it gradually before moving
on to the next
issue and i honestly think that's part
of why the hbo watchman tv series
works it does its best to achieve a
density
comparable to the original work it's not
quite at the same level
but the fact that episodes come out one
per week is part of why it's able to get
away with it
binging the watchmen tv show would be
doing it a disservice
just like binging the issues would be
doing a disservice to the comics
and there's another thing you can do in
a comic that you can't do
with film television or even a prose
novel
and that is linger on a page and stay
in the moment when you're watching a
movie the only way to take in the story
is to allow it to continue playing to
keep
pulling you forward through the
narrative
sure if you're watching at home you can
pause
but that just gives you a solitary frame
to look at
out of 24 frames per second similarly
if you're reading a book you can re-read
a page
or even a chapter but you have to be
moving forward your eyes have to be
moving forward across
the words to get anything if you stop
reading the storytelling stops as well
you can't just look at a page of prose
and soak it in in the way you can with
the page of a
comic in these other mediums
you can't linger but with a comic
if you want to stay on a page it doesn't
fully stop your experience
it allows you to just take in more
of what's in front of you and then you
make the decision to move forward
you have agency in determining the
pacing not soul agency
there are multiple ways for writers and
artists to guide you
at the pace that they want like what i
talked about with the panel layouts
but it's still more than you'll have in
other mediums
in film or tv or pros you're either
moving forward through the story
or you're not taking part at all comics
let you pause
without disengaging video games are
really the only other narrative medium i
can think of that
allows for this as in some games you can
explore
and linger in an environment or a
setting before deciding to move the
story forward
but that's something that the developers
of a video game have to
allow for with comics it's intrinsic to
the medium
why does this matter well let's go to
the issue of the black
freighter as i mentioned in the comics
these digressions start out only a
couple of panels
on a handful of pages a reader could
linger
on these and think on the meaning behind
their inclusion or
they could glide right past give them
little to no
thought at first at least
because there's build up and eventually
it demands more attention over time
because by the end
the black freighter is taking up entire
pages it escalates
going from a scant few panels to the
entire page
and in the ultimate cut of watchmen
there's an animated adaptation of tales
from the black freighter spliced into
the film
and it forces the entire rest of the
movie to stop dead right from the very
first segment
as a viewer you no longer have a choice
as to whether this is something worth
paying attention to
with the film you are literally deprived
of anything else to focus on while it
gives you a black freighter segment
in the comic the initial injection of
those segments is small
almost missable and it evolves over the
issues until it demands your full
attention by taking up the entire page
it starts as a gentle poke and grows
louder until you
cannot ignore it anymore but i'm filming
the first injection of black freighter
material
is just as jarring as the last because
every single time
it demands the same amount of attention
i.e
all of it it doesn't escalate in
significance it
can't because the medium of film doesn't
have an equivalent way to drip feed it
from single panels on a grid to full
comic book pages
the film forces the flow breakage in a
way that commands attention
right from the start removing the
ability
to give it more and more focus which is
a major element of its existence in the
original work
now look it's honestly possible that the
entire black freighter segment
of the original is given more time than
it needs
i've seen the issue argued in both
directions but there is no question that
the way the film has to present
something like this
breaks the entire narrative flow over
its
knee and makes the viewers watch
additionally the way in which the
original story is broken up
by issues allows it to pivot in a way
that
does not translate very well to a
continuous medium like film
because there's a clean break with each
new issue
it isn't jarring or pace killing to have
an entire issue dedicated to the
comedian's backstory
or rorschach's mental state or dr
manhattan's origin
much like the chapter breaks in a novel
issue breaks provide a natural stopping
point
and if you have that you can pivot the
timeline
the character focus the point of view
it's just like my first example with
into the woods
using the intermission as a stopping
point to pivot
its story but film is a continual
experience
as i noted before it demands forward
momentum
stopping any forward momentum of the
plot to do what feels like a 20-minute
sidebar goes against the continuous
nature of watching a film because a film
doesn't have natural stopping points to
do that with
film doesn't have clean breaks like
intermissions chapters or separated
issues to segment the story and allow
for something to be more sectioned off
without feeling intrusive or tangential
which is how they end up coming across
in the movie
there are some ways to try and make
these divergences work better on film
but
snyder just took the way that moore did
it in the comic and left it as is
and it simply wasn't designed to work
this way
[Music]
in the case of a piece like watchmen the
issues of adaptation go
beyond just the story itself
the original work was a commentary on
the superhero genre in comics at the
time it was made it was commenting
on itself it existed in a specific
context that just wasn't the case for
the film version
especially not in 2009 and as a reminder
at the time the movie came out
there were only two films in the marvel
cinematic universe we'd only gotten the
second nolan batman film
a year before in other words superheroes
were not yet the biggest thing in the
medium of film
when moore wrote watchmen superheroes
were
practically the only game in town in the
medium of comic books
subgenres like horror western romances
had become extremely niche had had to go
into ben
independent or had vanished altogether
by and large if you bought a comic
it meant you were reading about
superheroes
that is the artistic world that watchman
existed in and was commenting on
a watchman film would honestly have a
lot more validity being released
right now when superheroes pretty much
are the biggest thing going on in film
and have been for a little while
that's part of why the amazon series the
boys is doing so well and no i
still haven't seen the boys i have no
interest in the source material and
even though i've heard good things about
how it was adapted i
i just haven't had the time but my point
is
that with superheroes being ubiquitous
in more and more entertainment mediums
now is the time for works like the boys
or watchmen
but that wasn't the world that the
watchmen film was released into
now one might conceivably therefore
argue that that just means it's gained
more significance since then and the
film was actually ahead of its time
and that's an interesting notion but
sadly i have to say no
that's that's not the case because it's
not commenting
on the world of superhero films in the
2010s and beyond
any more than it was commenting on the
superhero films of the 2000s
when it came out originally because of
how closely
watchmen the film sticks to the original
work
it's a 2009 film that's commenting on
the comic book world
of 1986 and some of the specifics of the
things that went on in the watchmen
comics were big
deals because of the state of the medium
at
the time take for instance the sex
scenes
between silk spectre and night owl at
that point in comics
sex was still pretty taboo as a topic
especially mainstream comics
the very existence of scenes like this
in a comic was unexpected and
off-putting
because this was the kind of thing that
genuinely felt like you shouldn't be
reading it
that's without getting into some of the
specifics like dan's erectile
dysfunction
in a superhero comic book what
superheroes didn't have sex on panel
in 1986 by contrast sex scenes and films
even big budget mainstream ones
haven't been taboo for decades so when
those same scenes
show up in a film it's not breaking any
new ground for the medium
it's not even that unexpected the same
scene
played the same way in a medium where
sex scenes are standard practice
loses the significance it had in its
original form
and suddenly you're wondering why is
that even there
i feel at this point it's worth actually
going over a little bit of history and
noting that snyder was not the first
director
to try and get this movie made the film
rights actually
got purchased before the comic was even
finished its run
those rights bounced around numerous
studios over about a two decade span
terry gilliam was attached for a while
but eventually he left because he came
to the conclusion that
nothing less than a five to six hour
mini-series was going to do the original
justice
he declared it unfilmable now
following the success of the first x-men
film in 2000 screenwriter david hader
worked on it at universal with hopes to
direct
he eventually left over creative
differences but his
script fell into the hands of a few more
directors after that including darren
aronofsky and paul greengrass
that was before ultimately landing in
the lap of zack snyder
at that point alex say whose career had
mostly been script doctoring
up to that point came in to shape the
script into what snyder
wanted to do with it this revision
actually brought the script more in line
with the comic
as among other things haters draft had
brought the timeline up to date
so that the film would be contemporary
this entire element got scrapped in
order to make it a period piece set in
the 1980s
which only served to emphasize that it
was commenting
on the past and not the present which is
another point the hbo series
successfully absorbed
so did the adaptation of moore's v for
vendetta come to think of it
it's been well documented at this point
that snyder appears to have used the
comic panels as storyboards for the film
mimicking the images rather than
adapting them and to be fair this had
worked for him once before when he
adapted frank miller's 300.
but there's just the simple fact that
300
is not watchmen and i don't mean that to
be derogatory but it's just not doing
anything close to the same thing
the entirety of 300 is double page
spreads
which means visually it already is in an
aspect ratio more akin to a movie screen
and the pacing of 300 is far closer to
that of a film
than a traditional comic anyways it
wasn't a thoughtful meditative piece on
the psychology of its characters it was
a propellant
thrill ride and that doesn't inherently
make it a worse comic
but that's not the point i'm trying to
make what that
makes it is a much cleaner fit for
film than watchmen would ever be
what worked for 300 would not work here
[Music]
now finally to try and drive home my
main point i want to illustrate
two specific things that the film
version of watchmen did
that actually reflect thoughtful
adaptation as a way to contrast
with the film's failure to do it pretty
much anywhere else
firstly ditching the squib was a good
idea
i know purists got up in arms over this
but it was the right call to make
especially at the time
taking the film on its own merits the
things that it would have had to have
done
to get audiences to go along with the
whole concept
of an interdimensional squid it was
simply not worth the effort
and don't forget the context that i
already mentioned about when this film
was released
we were still in the grounded realistic
phase of superhero movies
we were two years away from thor
starting to introduce
more outright fantastical elements into
comic book and superhero movies
and we were a full five years away from
guardians of the galaxy proving that it
was
actually safe to go completely bonkers
oh
yeah part of why the squid works
in the comic is that interdimensional
monsters
were standard for the genre at the time
but
that was not the case for superheroes on
film in 2009
and trying to go there would have lost
most of the audience
who weren't expecting it the hbo series
gets away with referencing the squid but
that's because it came out
at a point when audiences have gotten
used
to that level of insanity in superhero
shows and movies
but back in 2009 tying the destruction
of new york to dr manhattan
was cleaner and it kept the end result
intact
it accounts for what the comic was able
to get away with that the film
would not have been able to and then
there's the one part
of the entire movie where zack snyder
truly
took advantage of what film can do that
comics can't
and that the opening credit montage
the interplay of music and image the
choice of song
the pace of it how it establishes the
alternate world in which the story takes
place
it's all done in a way that takes
maximum advantage of what can be done
with film
that couldn't be done in a comic
in the comic book the information that
gets
delivered in this montage is interwoven
and interspersed as small details
dropped in
as little side things in a scene or in a
little bit of dialogue and passing
now the lazy way to do this and
establishing a film would have been with
a text crawl
or a voice over at the start of the film
but instead
snyder makes use of the interplay of
image and sound at the disposal
of a filmmaker to provide the same vital
details in a way
unique to the movie it's amazing it's
easily the best part of the entire film
and it reflects the most thoughtful
piece of adaptation the thing has to
offer
but it's only used to set up the world
as efficiently as possible and being
efficient
means you absolutely have to take
advantage of your medium
and then after that it settles into just
retelling the comic
in a format that it wasn't meant to be
told in
it's a tiny glimpse of the possibilities
of
what a properly adapted watchman movie
might have been
or maybe it's actually a glimpse into
why this project was doomed from
inception
watchmen is so specifically tailored to
comics
not only the comic book format but the
world of comics at the time it was
written
that to do everything necessary to
properly
fit that story into the medium of film
and to say about
film superheroes what the original said
about comic book superheroes
that might honestly have required so
many changes that
we would have been left wondering is
this even still watchmen
i brought up the hbo series a few times
already and the single smartest thing
that show did was not
adapt to the original work instead it
did a follow-up story
set in the present timeline of the world
that the
watchmen comic book had depicted and
that new story
is specifically tailored to the
television format
that it's being told in it's able to
evoke the original watchmen
it can play out the consequences from
that story it can bring in new elements
all without risking screwing it up in
translation
or as snyder's film did failing to
translate it very much at all
[Music]
loyalty to the original work is
important in any adaptation but it's not
the only thing that will make or break
the end product
if you don't tailor the work for the new
medium
properly then you haven't really adapted
it
you've just retold it in a way that it
wasn't meant to be told
you've taken a story out of its element
and made it less effective
as a result and the more that story took
advantage of its original format
the more glaring this issue is going to
be
and that the strict adherence to the
original text
is the ultimate failing of zack snyder's
watchman
a noble failing perhaps rooted in a
desire to honor
the original most certainly but a
failing
nonetheless heard joke once
men goes to doctor says he's depressed
says life seems harsh and cruel
says treatment is simple the great film
director zack snyder is in town tonight
go and see him you'll embrace the
darkness
man bursts into tears says
but doctor i am
zack snyder good joke
everybody laugh roll on snare drum
curtains
[Music]
so that's watchmen and
my reasons why i think the movie doesn't
work like i said mine's not the only
take out there i've seen some terrific
breakdowns as to
some of the problems with this that are
more rooted in the changes that were
made
and indication of snyder's
misunderstanding of some of the
characters i've seen that brought up by
youtubers like movie bob or maggie mae
fish
feel free to check out their videos on
snyder as a filmmaker for a
more insight on that but this has
always been what bugged me about the
watchmen movie
it adhered too close to the original for
it to ever work
and i felt like nobody ever brought that
up whenever they talked about why the
movie failed
if they thought it failed
if you liked the movie that's great
but i don't know anyone who doesn't
consider it the lesser version of the
story
and that need not it be the case for
adaptation
some people seem to take it as a given
while like of course the original's
better like it's not always though
it doesn't have to be the lesser version
of the exact same thing
and that's why i refuse to accept that
absolute loyalty is a good thing
so there you go folks thanks for going
through this journey with me
this one took a lot of time and took a
lot of work and i've been thinking about
for a long time
it's probably going to be a little while
before i do something this big again
i need to focus on getting the novel out
and also honestly i could use a minor
breather that doesn't mean there's going
to be fewer videos it'll still be too
weak that'll stay but like i'm not doing
something this big for a little bit
i got to catch up on some stuff if you
want to help me out
and keep this whole thing going i got a
patreon um
but even if you're not able to support
me financially like share subscribe
all those things help as well whatever
you thought about what i said drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it but you also don't have to
because at the end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]